>>> MORE NUKES.
THAT'S NORTH KOREAN DICTATOR KIM
JONG-UN'S RESOLUTION FOR THE NEW
YEAR.
WORKING THE STORY, BRINE, HE
WANTS OTHER NEW WEAPONS OF WAR.
>> Reporter: ANY
INTERCONTINENTAL MISSILES AND
LAUNCHED A ROCKET RANGER THAT
PUTS ALL OF SOUTH KOREA IN
RANGE.
A NEW YEAR BRING AS NEW ROUND OF
THREATS FROM NORTH KOREA'S
COMBATIVE SOON TO BE 39-YEAR-OLD
DICTATOR.
KIM JONG-UN CITING AN INCREASED
THREAT HE PERCEIVES, CALLING FOR
MASS PRODUCTION OF TACTICAL NICK
CLEAR WEAPONS.
>> BAD ENOUGH AS IT IS ASSUMES
TENS OF NUCLEAR WEPS, CONTINUING
TO BUILD UP THAT BASE IS A
CHALLENGE.
>> Reporter: KIM ALSO CALLED FOR
DEVELOPMENT OF A NEW
INTERCONTINENTAL MILL BALLISTIC
SYSTEM FOR NORTH CHRISTINE
ROMANS.
ANALYSTS SAY KIM HAS TESTED
THOSE CAPABLE OF HITTING OF
CONTINENTAL UNITED STATES BUT
NEEDS THEM TO RE-ENTER THE
EARTH'S ATMOSPHERE.
>> INTERESTING THAT THEY
FLAGGED.
KIM FLAGGED THIS PAST WEEK OR SO
IS, THEIR INTEREST IN DEVELOPING
THAT REENTRANCE, TESTING IT IN
SOME CONSPICUOUS WAY WE CAN SEE.
>> Reporter: IN RECENT DAYS
BRAGGED ABOUT THIS WEAPON
CALLING THE COUNTRY'S "SUPER
LARGE MULTIPLE ROCKET LAUNCHER"
IT SAYS WAS TEST FIRED OVER THE
WEEKEND AND KIM CLAIMS CAN BE
LOADED WITH TACTICAL WARHEADS.
HIS SWAGGER HAS SHOWN NO SIGNS
OF LESSENING.
IN MID-NOVEMBER AS HE OVERSAW
THE TEST LAUNCH OF ONE ICBM, HAD
IN TOE A YOUNG GIRL BELIEVED TO
BE HIS DAUGHTER, WHO IS AROUND
10 YEARS OLD, RARELY, IF EVER,
SEEN IN PUBLIC BEFORE.
IN PRIVATE, THE PALACE INKRIEG
INTRIGUE IS AS FORMIDABLE AS
EVERY.
HE JUST FIRED THE MOST POWERFUL
MAN IN NORTH KOREA, OTHER THAN
HIMSELF.
>> THIS COULD BE THE INTERNAL
GAME OF THRONES INSIDE NORTH
KOREA.
NOT ABLE TO ACHIEVE OBJECTIVES
AND LIKELY MAKING PERSONNEL
CHANGES.
THE OTHER THING WE'RE SEES, OF
COURSE, HE CAN ACCEPT NO
FAILURE.
MUST HAVE SCAPEGOATS.
>> Reporter: HOW SHOULD THEY WEE
RESPOND TO THE THREATS?
STRENGTHEN ALLIANCES KEEP UP
JOINT MILITARY DRILLS AND FIND
OTHER WAYS TO PUT PRESSURE ON